hi Polar 18 super dass ihr jetzt bei
klickzom seid denn da habe ich auch
gleich mal zwei Fragen an
Euch erste Frage ist ich habe irgendwie
gehört dass der Name Polarkreis 18
irgendwie davon kommt dass einer von
euch nur
Z hat weiß nicht ob das
stimmt und die zweite Frage ist wie
steht ihr zu zu dem illegalen Downloaden
von Musik sei es auf Youtube oder auf
irgendeiner Tauschbörse
danke wenn ihr die Fragen beantwortet
also unsere Geschichte also erstmal
danke dass du dass du
diese Fragen uns gestellt hast ist
übrigens sehr interessant hier diese
lustigen Menschen zu sehen auf dem auf
dem iPad aber unser Bandname kommt
tatsächlich daher dass mein Vater in den
80er Jahren eine Expedition zum
Polarkreis unternommen hat und
dort etwas schlecht ausgerüstet waren
ihm dabei zwei Z ab gefroren sind und er
deshalb jetzt nur noch
1 hat und deshalb der Name Polarkreis
ähm das weiteren die zweite Frage war
ähm illegale down ach so illegale
Downloads
[Musik]
ähm illegale Downloads also dass Leute
unsere Musik sozusagen kostenfrei ähm
sich
äh besorgen bzw irgendwie eigen zu eigen
machen das ist äh etwas was leider der
Lauf der Dinge ist sich darüber zu
ärgern wäre schlecht denn man sollte
sich nicht über Dinge ärgern die man
nicht ändern
kann